[موسيقى]
اذا ارادت دوله ما شن حرب على دوله اخرى
فهي ليست بالضروره في حاجه الى غازلها
يكفي ان تغرقها بالمواد المخدرات هذه
خلاصه انتهى اليها تاجر مخدرات اليمني
سابق في قصه ليلى وهو يتساءلون كغيره عن
اسباب رخص اسعار المواد المخدره في دولنا
العربيه
الدقيقه والمحدثه عن تجاره المخدرات
وتعاطيها في عالمنا العربي فاننا نرصد
مؤشرات مفزعه عن انتشارها بين اليافعين
والشبان في دول عربيه مختلفه والحقيقه ان
هذه الظاهره الخطيره ظاهره عالميه تحذر
منها تقارير الامم المتحده التي تربط بين
ارتفاع معدلات انتشار المخدرات وتزايد
الامراض والشراء من المرتبطه في قصتنا
الشباب العربي والمخدرات يطلعون ابو يزن
وهو احد
تجار المخدرات السابقين في اليمن على
تجربته في هذا العالم كما نعين بؤرا
لتعاطي المخدرات في لبنان وتونس ونستقصي
بدايه انزلاق الشبان الى تعاطي المخدرات
والادمان ومدى ارتباط هذا الظروف السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه نستكمل بقيه
قصتنا مع ضيفنا الدكتور محمد المهدي استاذ
الطب النفسي بجامعه الازهر والى الاعرج
المدير التنفيذي لشبكه الشرق الاوسط
وشمالي افريقيا للحد من مخاطر استخدام
المخدرات نسال ضيفينا عن كيفيه تصنيف
المواد المخدره ودرجه خطورتها وتاثيراتها
الجسديه والنفسيه
والاساليب الترويش لها خاصه في عالم
الانترنت وغيره من الوسائط الحديثه والسبل
والوقايه شبابنا من الانزلاق الى تعاطي
المخدرات ومتطلبات استرداد من ساقه الى
هذا العالم لكن قبل ان نبدا الحوار
شهد القصه
[موسيقى]
عملت حادث
بدراجه ناريه وكنت معناتها تحت تاثير
المخدرات في اللحظه هذيك كنت طاير في عالم
اخر ما انا عارف انه صحيح في صور متحركه
تشير تقارير الامم المتحده الصادره في شهر
حزيران لعام 2021 الى ارتفاع مطارد
ومتزايد بنسب انتشار المخدرات عالميا
يرافقها ارتفاعها في نسب الامراض والجرائم
المترتبه على استهلاك المخدرات
لكن ما فاجانا خلال بحثنا قله الاحصائيات
المتعلقه بالعالم العربي حيث ان معظمها
يعود لعده سنوات سابقه بما فيها التقديرات
التي يصدرها سنويا المكتب الاقليمي للامم
المتحده المعني بالمخدرات والجري
المفروض يجي حكيم يتحدث على
الكورونا يتحدث هذه اللي هي ممتده عندها
سنين ومرتده وقاعده تتفيقم
وتهدد في تركيبه المجتمع وفي نسيج المجتمع
نفسه
في الاردن لمعرفه اسباب قله المعلومات
والابحاث المختصه بهذا الشان في المنطقه
العربيه لكن لم يتم تجاوب مع طلباتنا
المتكرره بمنح اي لقاء او بالاجابه على
تساؤلاتنا
قله المعلومات تلك دفعتنا للبحث ميدانيا
عن نماذج من عده دول عربيه لاستكشاف واقع
انتشار المخدرات
وتونس ولبنان
رحله بحثنا لم تكن مهمه سهله
اكبر تجار المخدرات السابقين في اليمن
[موسيقى]
عملنا هذا في سوق المخدرات عمل خطير وفي
كثير من المشاكل
فاذكر انه في يوم من الايام يعني تشاجرت
مع احد المنافسين اللي في السوق بسبب
ولاخر
والثوره المشاجره الى النعم دخلنا في
العراق
[موسيقى]
بسيطه
كل ما يعرف الثاني ما احد يعرف احد كيف
كيف لو تم القبض على حدا
ناصر الكبير
[موسيقى]
في تونس انتهى بنا المطاف في هذه المنطقه
الخطره والنشطه ببيع واستهلاك المخدرات
في احد ازقتها تحدث الينا بحذر هذا الشاب
الذي عرف عن نفسه باسم سمير والذي نجح في
التعافي من الادمان اثر حادثه كادت ان
تفقده حياته وهو تحت تاثير المخدر
بصعوبه تمكنا من اقناع سمير الاستحاضنا
بشكل سري الى بعض نقاط بيع المخدرات
السيد السيد وبيكلمني دخلت له صفقه فهمت
كيفاش
اجاني انت
في غابه
تمام
بعد ساعات طوال من مراقبهنا حركه البيع في
هذه المنطقه
نجحنا من خلال سميره في الحديث مع احد
المشترين والمتعاطيين للمخدرات
[موسيقى]
اول مره خطيه مخدرات
صغير خمسه سته ابتدائي
سته ابتدائي
تتكيف حبيت نجرب
نجربها المره الاولى المره الثانيه
[موسيقى]
شكلك حاجتك مع اولاد في الحكومه
في لبنان الذي يعاني من العديد من الازمات
الاقتصاديه المتلاحقه تمكنا من الوصول الى
احد بؤر تعاطي المخدرات بمساعده مدمنين
السابقين
والسلام عليكم
ورحمه
[تصفيق]
الله
اني بلشنا نحنا كم عمري 13 سنه
كيف حسب البيئه الواحد بيرضى
خلاص اول مره كمان
غلط غلط كان 12 سنه 13 سنه
المجتمع خاصه المجتمع الي انا كنت فيه
كانه يستخفوا بموضوع الحشيش لانه الحشيش
ما بتسبب مشكله الحشيش ما فيها ادمان كنت
احضر افلام وكنشوف ابر والشام وغير مواد
مخدرات
يلي انا ما تخيلت اني اوصل لها على 14 سنه
ونص اخذت معي سنه ونص لاحط اول ابره بايدي
يؤكد تاجر المخدرات ابو يزن ان مخدر
الحشيش يعتبر بوابه الولوج لعالم الادمان
لذا يستخدمه تجار المخدرات بطرق مختلفه
لتسريع عمليه انتشار المخدرات
بالنسبه للحشيش في هناك نوع يسمى الحشيش
يعني الحشيش المخلوط بماده المخدرات وهذا
النوع خطير جدا خطير جدا لانه المتعاطي ها
يكون مدمن في وقت سريع
اسباب انتشار المخدرات عالميا لكن البطاله
والواقع الاقتصاديه الصعب يعتبران السبب
الاهم الانتشارها حيث تظهر الارقام
والرسوم البيانيه في تقارير مكتب جريمه
والمخدرات في الامم المتحده ارتفاعا
انتشار المخدرات في المجتمعات ذات الدخل
المتدمي بينما ينخفض انتشارها في
المجتمعات ذات الدخل المرتفع
خلال تصويرنا في تونس اخبرنا سمير بان احد
اهم اسباب انتشار المخدرات في منطقته يعود
لركام هذا المصنع الضخم الذي كان قبل وقت
قصير احد اشهر مصانع الطوب الاحمر
ومشتقاته وكانت تصل صادراته الى عده دول
اوروبيه
[موسيقى]
فساد المالي والفساد اللي اداري والواحد
هاك تشوفه شنو صار فيه ولد شباب الكل جاي
تتعاطى المخدرات
[موسيقى]
السياسيه
ينشغل بها الشاب ينشغل بها الطفل
الاسباب في الدول العربيه تتكاثر عن
الاسباب الي بغير بلاد ليش
اولا ما بعرف ليه او في اعرف ليه بسمعها
بصراحه كثير احكي بموضوع دايما في رخص
بالمواد او المخدرات الدول العربيه اكثر
من غير بلاد هذا الشيء انا لاحظته
لما بقول كيماويات عم يبيعون الدولار
الدولار
رحت العمليه كده فتره انتكاسي عم فتش بدي
اجيب الجران 250 دولار
طفل يكون 250 دولار بده يجيب او مراهق بده
يجيب او حتى صاحب عمل هالايام بينعمل حساب
للواحد بده يدفع 250 دولار على الجرام
وليش الدولار
الحروب
بلد اخرى همم
تدخل الكميات كبيره من هذه المخدرات البلد
هذه همم
وتستعمل ايضا بطريقه توزيعه عبر خلايا عبر
شبكه
واسعار رخيصه جدا فهذا يكون موجود في
السوق بشكل كبير وهمم
اللي همم
[موسيقى]
احد اهم تداعيات واقع انتشار المخدرات
ارتفاع نسب العنف والجريمه في المجتمع حيث
تشير هذه الدراسه الصادره عام 2020
المديريه الامن العام في الاردن الى
ارتباط المخدرات بمعدلات نسر ارتفاع
الجريمه مما يهدد السلم والامن المجتمعي
وتموت وانت ما في بالك شبيها يعني ضربه
الاسره ضربه مؤسسه الاسره الثانيه
واحد يشبه عين زوجته واحد يعني يعني تقرا
الجنايه مستغرب
المخدرات هي بنفسها جريمه
وتجرك الى الجريمه جرائم اخرى مثل القتل
مثل الاقتصاد مثل السرقه وكثير من الجرائد
يعني الواحد يعني يتعاطى المخدرات
في كثير من المشاكل والجرائم هذا اللي
حصلوا الحق
خلاص المخدرات
تفرض الدول العربيه قوانين مشدده على
تجاره وتعاطي المخدرات لكن مع الانتشار
المتزايد بدات بعض الدول العربيه اعاده
دراسه هذه القوانين ضمن استراتيجيه تهدف
الى تسديد عقوبه من يتاجر بها بينما يعاد
النظر في القوانين التي تحاكم ضحاياها
كمجرمين
الموجوده
والجريمه تنفتحها على جرائم اخرى اكبر
والمطلوب الان نقول في تونس مثلا الان
مطروح في البرلمان في كم من فتره حقبه
زمنيه تروح هذا الموضوع على اساس تعديل
القانون بماء همم
يسمح ب- همم على قلب بالنسبه
للمتعاتي والمتعاتي في اول مره على الاقل
يفسح له المجال بلا عقاب البديل
والعقاب العلاجي خلينا نقولو معنا لانه مر
للعلاج انه
اشياء ردعيه تكون فيها خطايا ماليه ما
تكونش فيها يعني سجن لان السجن مباشره هو
مش تصبح ديمومه للمتعاتي فيها وانفتاح على
همم
[موسيقى]
باب الجري معنا
الحبس
انا عم بتفاعل ما عم يجرني
طيب شو حاطلع
حاطلع محسن مع اب اطلع كبت حقا ومتعلم من
مجرمين يمكن روح انفذ يصير مجرم
على ايدك اليمين اهو نقضيه
[موسيقى]
جدا خطيره جدا
وتسميها بالعربي جهاز البيولوجيا الانسان
وصعوبه رحلته في التعافي منها دفعته
للتخصص في الدراسه وعلاج الادمان ولاحقا
اسس مع مختصين مركزا لعلاج الادمان
لمساعده الضحايا انطلاقا من واقع تجربته
القاسيه ونجاح في الخلاص منها
انا بدي اشتغل بشيء كانت 50
خلص يعرف طريقه ويعرف لوين بده يروح يعرف
شو بده بالحياه
بده يقوم كل يوم ويشتغل على هذا الهدف
وفعلا هذا اللي عملته من ال2000 201
تنوعت التحديات والصعوبات التي واجهتنا
خلال بحثنا وتصويرنا هذا الفيلم من اجل
الكشف عن هذا الجزء البسيط من الواقع
المخيف الذي يواجه الاجيال الشابه في مشرق
ومغرب الدول العربيه لكن يبقى التحدي
الاكبر قدره المجتمعات العربيه على التحرك
بخطن اسرع لمواجهه هذا الخطر المتزايد قبل
فوات الاوان
في مكافحه المخدرات وتتشارك المعلومات
بشانها لانقاذ الارواح وتشير تقارير
الامميه الى ان تعاطي المخدرات قتل وحده
ما يقرب من نصف مليون شخص خلال عام 2019
وقد اكد الامين العام للامم المتحده ان
الاستثمار في الوقايه والسيطره على تعادل
المخدرات واضطرابات التعاطي يحققان عوائد
قويه مثل انقاذ الارواح وزياده صحه السكان
وتحسين المشاركه القوى الانتاجيه وتقليدي
تكاليف العداله الجنائيه واشار تقدير امم
الى ان حوالين 2005 و70 مليون شخص تعاطوا
المخدرات عام 2020 والارقام تتزايد
باستمرار للاسف خاصه في الدول الناميه
والفقير والتحضن القضيه باهتمام الامم
المتحده ومنذ عام
وقررت ثلاث معاهدات لمكافحه المخدرات من
لتنسيق دولي للحد من اساءه استخدام
الادويه للغير الاغراض الطبيه وفرض النظام
رقابه دوليه على المؤثره العقليه كما حددت
التدابير وعمليه لمكافحه التجاره
بالمخدرات اذا عدنا الان الى واقعنا
العربي فالمؤشرات تبدو مفزعه في العراق
على سبيل المثال صرح مسؤول بان اكثر من 50
بالمئه من الشباب العراقي
يتعاطون المخدرات مشيرين الى ان مروجي
المخدرات ينتشرون في كل المناطق اما في
النسب فقد بلغت نسبه تعاطي المواد المخدره
نحو سته في المئه متراجعه في الواقع بشكل
ملحوظ عن النسبه التي سجلتها قبل سبع
سنوات وهي 10%
مسؤولون سودانيون اشاره الى ان عددا
مدمنين بلغ سته ملايين في السودان مؤكدين
صعوبه حصر الاعداد الحقيقيه قراءه فش
المخدرات بين الشبان وتثير البيانات
الرسميه في مختلف الدول العربيه في الواقع
عن الكميات الهائله المصادره من المواد
المخدره تثير القلق مما يراد بهذه الامه
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مجددا المشاهدين الكرام ونرحب
بضيفينا الكريمين في هذه الحلقه من مدينه
المنصوره المصريه الدكتور محمد المهدي
استاذ الطب النفسي في جامعه الازهر ومن
بيروت الى الاعرج المديره التنفيذي لشبكه
الشرق الاوسط وشمالي افريقيا للحد من
مخاطر
استخدامين نبدا معك السيد علي الاعرج
في الخريطه العالميه لانتشار هذه الافه
اين موقعنا نحن الدول العربيه
مساء الخير لك ولضيفك وللمشاهدين بالمبدا
نحنا يعني لسنا بموقع مختلف كثيرا عن
غيرنا لانه ما يشجعنا اكثر هون بالمنطقه
انه لا زالت الروابط العائليه لا زال
الوازع الديني يلعب دور في موضوع الوقائي
ورد ببعض يعني بالمقدمه او يمكن بالتقرير
فكره انه دائما ان احنا نعيش مؤامره وفي
ناس عم بيعملوا علينا حروب مثل ما ذكر ابو
يزن همم
ضيفك بالتقرير همم مين عم يعمل مؤامره اذا
عم بيعملوا علينا مؤامره لان احنا مستقلين
من دورنا يعني لما بينذكر انه عم بيدخل
مخدرات على البلد هناك اجهزه مسؤوله عن
عدم ادخال هذه المخدرات هناك اجهزه مسؤوله
عن ضبط هذه المخدرات وعدم توزيعها
وبالتالي هناك على الضفه الاخرى هناك
الاهل وال- همم
الكنيسه والجامع والمدرسه اللي لازم
يلعبوا دور بموضوع الوقايه يسلحوا هؤلاء
الاطفال والشبان والشبات بان يرفضوا
استخدام المخدرات في حال انعرضت عليهم
فنحنا موقعنا اا فيني اقول اذا عم نحكي
فقط بالمنطقه العربيه مش شمال افريقيا
والشرق الاوسط لان احنا بنشتغلنا بشبكه
مناره من دون ايضا افغانستان باكستان
ايران وسوي هفاه عمليا موقعنا بالمنطقه
العربيه اليوم من
ولكن منا بحالي مدري وكانه همم كل شبابنا
صار وشباب
التقدير والارقام تتحدث بان هذه المواد
المخدره على خلاف اي منطقه في العالم في
منطقتنا العربيه تحديدا تكاد تكون في
متناول الجميع من الناحيه الماديه يعني
رخص هذه المواد لا يثير تساؤلات حقيقه
طبعا يعني سيدتي الكريمه طبعا التساؤلات
الاساسيه التي يثيرها هذا الموضوع هي انه
بيرجع بقول اين دور الاجهزه اين دور
الحكومات في تامين همم
المتطلبات للشبان والشبات خاصه للمراهقين
والمراهقات للاهل من من بمحاربه الفقر
يعني محاربه البطاله فرص عمل تعبئه او
اوقات الفراغ وبالتالي ايضا
بحسر الكميه يعني هناك بالعالم في
استراتيجيه الحد من العرض على المخدرات
هناك دور اساسي للحكومات بالحد من العرض
كثره العرض رح تخفض السعر
وكما وانه هناك اليوم بعد الدول للاسف
فيها انتاج انتاج وتوزيع ضمن المنطقه
العربيه هذا ما يحتاج ايضا الى ضبط بشكل
اساسي
انا بس عم بجرب بجرب يقول انه ما نروح على
الانديوزر يعني مش المستخدم المخدرات هو
هو المجرم مثل يعني في مجرمين اخرين يمكن
مش بس التجار او المنتجين المخدرات
من هذه التجاره العالميه للاسف المربحه
سريعه عن الربح هو كبيره الربح في نفس
الوقت اتحول الان للدكتور محمد المهدي
اهلا بك دكتور محمد يعني ضيفنا الكريم
اشار الى ان الاسره للمجتمع للمؤسسات
الدينيه الوازعه الاخلاق وكل ذلك دور مهم
لكن ايضا ل همم المؤسسات الرسميه دور كبير
او ان اركز معك على الجوانب النفسيه
وغيرها يعني ما الحيز يمكن ان تشغله في ما
يخص توجه همم البعض لهذه الافه ما الاسباب
بطبيعته لديه رغبه
للاستمتاع هو يسعى نحو اللذه ويتجنب الالم
فدي يمكن التركيبه اللي بتجعل اعداد كبيره
من البشر يتورطون في طاعات المخدرات
فكلما زاد الالم في حياه الانسان ظروف
سياسيه صعبه ظروف اقتصاديه صعبه ظروف
اجتماعيه صعبه
فيلجا الانسان الى هذا الترويح التدميري
بانه يتعاطى المخدرات
وقد يكون ذلك حل اا عنده حل سريع همم
يستريح اليه وقد تستريح بعض الدول الى انه
يعني نسبه من شبابها تتوجه هذا التوجه همم
حتى لا يسيروا المشاكل والزوابع والثورات
والانتفادات وهذه الاشياء
فيصبح تعاطي المخدرات عامل اا تهدئه اا
يرضى به الجميع وربما يتفق عليه جميع سرا
همم لانه همم يعني يجعل ال ال المتعاطي في
حاله خمود وخمول وراحه ولا مبالاه وربما
سعاد زائفه او وقتيه ويجعل ايضا المجتمعات
في حاله من همم
الاستقرار الزائف الذي ربما تراه حلا همم
ظروف معينه همم ربما انه له هؤلاء الشباب
في حاله وعي كامل همم ممكن يثيره الكثير
من المشاكل
اليها دكتور محمد يتحول مره اخرى
ان كان لنا الان نفصل قليلا في هذه المواد
المخدره كيف يمكن تصنيفها باعتقادك ونتحدث
عن المنطقه العربيه من اكثر انتشارا ما
الاكثر تعاطيا ان صح تعبير ما اا الاوسع
توزيعا همم بكذلك ما المعلومات المتوفره
لديكم بهذا الخصوص
ان احنا بالجمعيه عندنا شبكه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا الحجم المخاطر استخدام
المخدرات اللي انطلقت بدايه بمبادره من
مكتب الاقليمي لمنظحه المنظمه الصحه
العالميه واليوم المسجل لك جمعيه دوليه في
لبنان نعمل تقريبا على 20 بلد وكل حوالي
سنتين او ثلاثه من نعمل مثل تقييم للواقع
بها المناطق اخر تقييم صدر التقرير تبعه ب
تقديرنا عم بحكي هون بالتحديد هناك ما
يزيد عن مليون مستخدم للمخدرات عن طريق
الحكم
في المنطقه العربيه ولكن ايضا هناك يعني
مخاطر يتعرض لها هؤلاء كما انه اذا بنطلع
بنشوف انه في تحول تدريجي من استخدام
المخدرات عن طريق الحقن الى المخدرات
الحديثه اللي فيها مواد كيميائيه اللي
بتؤذي كثير واللي تؤخذ عن طريق الفم منها
مثلا اللي المشهور اكثر شيء اليوم اخذ
الضجه المنطقه هو الكبده جون مثلا فعمليا
همم ما في احصائيه ببلدان تقدر تقول لك
عدد مستخدمين مخدرات في شيء بقول لك انه
اكيد بالسنوات الاخيره لاحظنا ازدياد
باستخدام المخدرات لاحظنا انخفاض
الازدياد لانه متوفره لانه هناك تبسيط
لانه هناك ما يجعل الشبان والشبات يائسين
امام الواقع السياسي في الدول يعني تحول
للدكتور
ضيفنا الكريم سيد علي وانت منذ قليل ايضا
تحدث عن همم الجو السياسي عن جانب همم
السياسي قد تنجح هذه المخدرات انتشرت في
اوساط الشباب والشعوب في تخديرهم ان صح
التعبير عن المطالبه بحقوقهم الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه لكنها في المقابل لا تحل
المشاكل تخليق جرائم تخلق مجتمع يعني
يعاني من امراض النفسيه والجسديه ومن هنا
نود ان نفهم منك وتفصل المشاهد الكريم
يعني مقابل ما يمكن ان تسعى اليه بعض
الانظمه من استقرار مزيف مثل ما ذكرت همم
النقائص الاخرى او السلبيات التي يمكن ان
تدمر المجتمعات ايضا
يعني هو طبعا
اندماج الشباب في تعاطي المخدرات ده شيء
كريسي بالنسبه لاي دوله لانه في العالم
العربي بالذات نسبه الشباب هي النسبه
لاعلى في اغلب المجتمعات العربيه زي ما
كانتش كلها فحوالي مثلا 40% من التركيبه
السكانيه تحت سن 40 سنه في كثير من الدول
العربيه والمفروض ان دي ثروه مهمه جدا
بيحسدونا عليها في العالم كله ان احنا ال-
ال- التركيبه السكانيه اغلبها شبابيه غير
اوروبا مثلا تلاقي كبار السن هم الغالبيه
او اكثر همم هذه الطاقه الشبابيه للاسف
الشديد العالم العربي لا يستفيد منها فهي
طاقه مهمشه او تعيش في حاله اغتراب
ومخدره وتعيش في حاله الاغتراب وربما في
حاله تازه من مخارج حاله الاغتراب او ثم
عند الشاب انه ربما يخرج الى التطرف ربما
يخرج الى الارهاب ربما يخرج الى الى
المخدرات ربما ينسحب تماما من
الحياه العامه من الافق العام كله
محمد
المخدرات الان باعتقادكم من خلال خبراتك
في هذا الموضوع ما الذي يجلب فئه معينه من
الشباب بيحد ذاتها الى المخدرات وليس
وسائط اخرى او وسائل اخرى ل- اا التنفيذ
لانها الحل الاسهل والامن اا انه هياخد
حاجه هتعطيه احساس بالنشوه والسعاده حتى
ولو كانت وقتيه او تخمد وعيه او تطفئ وعيه
او تعطيه هلاوث يسعد بها في ظروف صعبه او
ظروف بائسه همم يعيش فيها لبعض الوقت وكل
ما يعني همم
تعقد وعيه اطفائه مره اخرى او شوهه او
غيره بالهلاوس والضلالات التي يعيش فيها
فهنا ده بيبقى حل سلبي امام الشاب اذا فقد
الحلم او فقد الامل او فقد التطلع الى
المستقبل او فقد العمل او فقد الرزق او
فقد ال- ال- الترابط الاجتماعي فده بيبقى
الحل وعند يتذوقه يدمنه وعندما يدمنه
يتحول الى طاقه تخريجيه في المجتمع
والكثير من الجرائم ربما 80% من الجرائم
جرائم العنف الوحشيه والغريبه والشاهذه
كانت تحت تاثير همم المخدرات
لانه المخدر بيعمل ايه المخدر
بيصب بط همم ملكه التحكم والشيطره في المخ
وهي موجوده في الفصل الامامي للمخ وفي نفس
الوقت او في نفس الوقت هذه المخدرات همم
الكثير منها وبالذات الحشيش والماري وانا
وال- والبانجو
والشاب او الكريستاله اا ودي منتشره كثيره
جدا في الدول العربيه همم هذه المواد
والكابتيجون بالمناسبه هذه المواد تحدث
حاله من الضلالات والهلاوس فالمريض يعتقد
انه في احد بيتامر عليه او في يحاول قتله
او يحاول وضع السموم لي او يعني يراقبوا
او يتبعه
تاج المخدرات السابقه الذي ادلى بشهادته
في الفيلم عن اييي
من يستعمل في الواقعه هذه المخدرات اشار
الى مثالين واحد صغير على مستوى صغير
الاخر على مستوى اكبر على بنت يمكن ان
تحقد على بنت اخرى فبالتالي همم تجعلها
مدمنه وتجرها الى هذا الموضوع وتحدث ايضا
على نطاق اوسع عن دوله قد تستهدف دوله
اخرى باغرقها واغرق اسواقها همم المخدرات
ماذا ترى في هذا الموضوع ما اهم الاساليب
للترويج او الافخاخ التي يمكن ان همم ربما
تقع فيها يقع فيها الافراد او حتى
المجتمعات ودول بعينها في هذا همم في هذه
الافه
على المستوى الفردي معروف عندنا في مجال
الطب النفسي انه المدمن يصنع اثنين مدمنين
في السنه
وهو يصنعهم اما لانه بيحاول ان هو يستفيد
من تعطيهم وان يتعاطى بجانبهم اذا كان
يعني في واحد غني او بنت غنيه او حاجه فدي
هتبقى فرصه انها توفر الماده لصديقتها
لشدتها لهذا الطريق على مستوى الدول طبعا
عندنا النموذج
التاريخي الكبير وهو حرب الافيون اللي
شنتها انجلترا على الصين
وكادت ان تنهي همم دوله الصين في بدايات
القرن العشرين واضطره الصين انها تعمل همم
عقوبه شديده جدا عقوبه الاعدام على
المدمنين على الرغم من انه هذا مخالف
للمعايير همم الطبيه والاعراف الطبيه
والانسانيه انه
من مريض وليس مجرم
فهناك الكثير من الدول والمجموعات
والاحزاب
التاريخيه
نعم حاليا يعني هناك دول يعني لا احب ذكر
اسماء حتى لا تدخل
النقاش في اه في في شكل يعني في تحيز او
حاجه لكن هناك دول همم تقوم همم زراعه
المخدرات
وتوزيعها وتوجعها ليه دول اخرى مجاوره
بهدف التاثير على شبابها او همم يعني همم
نتحدث ونحن نتحدث عن السليب همم الترويش
والطرق ل همم استهداف الافراد او حتى
المجتمعات اكبر بهذه الماده نتحدث ايضا عن
القنوات التي يحدث فيها ذلك هناك في
الواقع تقارير متضاربه في هذا الخصوص عن
الانترنت عن وسائل تواصل الاجتماعي
وغيره من الوسائط
الانترنت كيف ترى مختلف هذه الوسائط فيما
يخص هذا الموضوع اي دور تلعبوه
بس بدايه بدك تسمحي لي يعني يعني سجل تحفظ
على بعض الاسقاطات يا اللي عملنا بدون ما
ننتبه نحن نوسم هؤلاء الشبان والشبات
مستخدمين مخدرات انا
باعترف انه اكيد هناك همم مجرمين اللي هن
التجار او حتى المروجين ولكن خلينا نميز
بين المستخدم المخدرات مثل ما ذكر الدكتور
محمد انه المدمن مريض وليس مجرم ولا ايه
لا يوجد وصفه لاين كان فقط
الفيلم
الشباب
في التحذير من هذا الموضوع حتما ان المدمن
هو ضحيه للاسف لنفسه اولا المجتمع لظروفه
هو غيره
وسناتي لنتحدث ايضا عن هذه النقطه الان
تفضل لك
اوكي
بالنسبه للقنوات اكيد اليوم في سهوله اكثر
هناك ببعض الدول مساء اذا بدي اخذ لبنان
لما ابتدا الحديث عن تشريع زراعه الحشيش
من اجل اهداف طبيه اثار بين الشبان
والشبيبات صار فيه يعني تبسيط لاستخدام
الحشيش بما انه الدوله راح تشرع زراعه
فليش ما بنستخدم وكان في توفر للماده طبعا
هناك ايضا مثل ما ذكرت الانترنت يا لليوم
موجود مع كل مع كل شخص من طفل شاب او غيره
في بعض يعني الناس بتستغل هذا الشيء لحتى
تروش المخدرات مثل ما بتروش الجار بالبشر
حتى او همم يعني همم
فات اخرى يعني عبر الانترنت همم بالاضافه
لانه طبعا ال- همم العلاقات اللي عم-
الشبكات اللي عم تخلق للترويج هي اللي عم
بتساهم اكثر لان عم توصل مباشره للاشخاص
يعني اكثر شيء بتكون هذه همم يعني
حتى يعني ان نوسع النقاش قليلا طبعا نود
ان نقف عند بعض المشاركات التي اخذناها من
مختصين ايضا في هذا المجال الدكتوره
تتيانا نصار تقول ان الشخص الذي يلجا
لتعاطي المخدرات او ادمان اي شيء هربا من
اوجاع جسديه او حتى عاطفيه وطلب للراحه
الداخليه تحذر من عواقب معاقبه متعاطي
المخدرات والمدمنيها بالسجن الدكتوره
هذه المواد اذا سجنت بالعكس تتطور الحاله
عن السياده ولا حيلجوا اكثر للمخدرات اللي
كان بقلب السجن او اللي كان برات السجن
خصوصيت ببعض البلدان العربيه المخدرات
موجوده بقلب السجون من هيك الافضل الشخص
اللي هو بيتعاطى مخدرات بس ما بيروش له
يكون شخص عم بروح على مركز للمساعده
وللعلاج من المخدرات
ويدعوا الاستشاري النفسي الدكتور مامون
بيض الى اتباع استراتيجيه لمواجهه ظاهره
الادمان وتعاطي المخدرات تقوم على عده
مستويات تشتمل على زياده جرعه التوعيه
الاجتماعيه واحتوى الشباب والتوسع في
تاسيس مراكز علاجيه للمدنين متابعه
تاسيس مراكز علاجيه متخصصه على مستوى عالي
لان العلاج رحله طويله تغطي الجانب الطبي
والجانب النفسي والجانب الاسري والجانب
الاجتماعي والجانب الاخضر ثم المستوى
الثاني هو على مستوى التوعيه المجتمعيه
ايضا على عديدنا في المستويات توعيه
الاباء والامهات
لعوامل الادمان والكشف المبكر ثم ال ال
الاقتراب اكثر من شريحه الشباب سواء في
المدارس او في الجامعات من همم من خلال
الانشطه التوعويه ولابد من توفير الانشطه
الشبابيه التي تملا اوقات الشباب
طبعا هذا كان ايضا راي الدكتور مامون مبيض
اعود اليك سيد الي الاعرج يعني لا يوجد اي
بصمه لهؤلاء الشباب ندرك تماما انها افه
اجتماعيه لا احد للاسف في مامن منها لن
وجهه الاتهام لهؤلاء بقدر ما نود ان ننشر
الوعي بخصوص هذا الموضوع وكيفيه معالجته
وبالتالي السؤال ده مدى خطوره وسمها هؤلاء
بالفعل من قبل المجتمع هل المجتمعاتنا
يعني باتت مهيئه للتعامل اكثر في هذه
الارقام اما ان هذا الموضوع ما زال من
ابوهات
بعده هالموضوع من المحاضر طبعا هناك مشكله
كبيره بموضوع القوانين القمعيه اللي ما
بتخلي هؤلاء الشبان والشبابات يتوجهوا
لطلب الخدمات وبالتالي بتعرضهم لمخاطر من
خلال استخدام همم
للمخدرات بطرق يعني بتعرض لهم صحتهم
لالتقاط عدوى التهاب الكبد او لالتقاط
عدوى ال اتش اي في وسواها همم بالنسبه لنا
كمان ما بتخلينا نعرف فعلا شو حجم المشكله
يعني ما راح فيك بالدولنا ما في رقم بيقول
لك الارقام اللي بتصدر عن الشرطه اللي
بتقول انه ضبطنا هالقد عدد اشخاص عم
بيستخدم المخدرات او اشخاص مرتبطين بجرائم
مرتبطه بالمخدرات يلي مش بالضروره يكون
كلهم بس مستخدمين بيكون في معهم مروجين او
تشجي اما بالنسبه لان احنا بنعتبر كمان
انه همم في ضروره مثل ما قال دكتور مامون
في ضروره انه نبدا بالوقايه احنا ما بنحب
حدا ياخذ مخدرات ولكن لما نروح
يعني نقدر نعمل الوقايه من بعد في اشخاص
اخذوا المخدرات ويجب علينا كحومات وكمجتمع
مدني انه نامن لهم كل الخدمات اللازمه من
العلاج الى التاهيل الى اعاده الاخيرات
الاجتماعي والمهني وبالتالي حمايه من انه
يرجعوا ولكن خلينا نقول انه بدي رست اثبتت
انه مستخدمين مواد الافيونيه واللي ادمنوا
عليا وهنا عم نحكي عن الهرهون اللي اكثر
شيء معروف في فقط 30% منهم قدروا يظهروا
على مدى 30 40 سنه يعني بهل 10 سنين العمر
لا يستطيعون الخروج من الادمان 30% فقط
خرجوا
عم بحكي عن هذا حتى اللي خرجوا من الادمان
عملوا عده مرات يعني
علاجه تاهيل عم دخلوا عده مرات على السجون
تعرضوا لجرعه الزائده ولكن كانوا يتعرضوا
الانتكاسه من بعدها في منهم قدروا يضهروا
70% هيفضلوا هيك انا الميه بالميه من
هؤلاء الشبان والشبابات بدي اياهم يكونوا
فاعلين بالمجتمع لها السبب استراتيجيه لحد
من مخاطر استخدام المخدرات تقترح موضوع
علاج لان اليوم صار عم يتطبق بيعدل الدول
لبنان المغرب بعد دول الخليجرام
نعم هو علاج عباره عن علاج
بالمواد الافيونيه يعطى للشخص لانه
ادمان اليوم على خاصه يعتبر من نوع من مرض
مزمن فيعطي لهذا هؤلاء الاشخاص على مدى
الحياه هو مادي ياخذها تغنيه عن
الواحد
لاناس مختصين ومن هنا سؤالي للدكتور محمد
همم المهدي دكتور محمد باعتقد كدول عربيه
هل لدينا البنيه التحتيه اللازمه لمعالجه
هذه الافه بطرق علميه مثل ما كان يتحدث
سيد اليه الاعرج
قبل ما اجاوب على السؤال بس هو اللي
بيتكلم عنه الاستاذ الي ماده الميتادون
وده بيبقى بديل للهيروين او الافيونات على
وجه الخصوص ودي في عيادات في الغرب بتصرف
هذه الماده تحت اشراف طبي حتى لا يتعرض
مدمن الهالوين او الافيون
للحقن الملوث او لانه يرتكب جرائم علشان
يحصل على الماده وهي بيعتبروها اقل يعني
ادمانيا من همم الهروين او الافيون ولكنها
ليست متاحه في غالبيه الدول العربيه حتى
الان همم لكن البنيه التحتيه لعلاج
الادمان في غالبيه الدول العربيه ايضا همم
يعني غير كافيه همم ربما في بعض الدول غير
موجوده همم لانه الادمان زي ما قال
الدكتور همم مامون بيحتاج له همم علاج
متعدد المستويات علاج جسدي وعلاج نفسي
وعلاج اجتماعي ايوه اجروا علاج روحي
ويحتاج لفريق متعدد التخصصات طبيب نفسي
اخصائي نفسي اخصائي اجتماعي اخصائي علاج
بالنشاط مرشد ديني لابد من هذا الفريق همم
لا تتواجد المجتمعات العلاجيه والمراكز
العلاجيه او المستشفيات العلاجيه اللي
تستوفي هذه الشروط كمان الفتره اللي
بيقضيها المدمن حتى يتخلص من اثار الادمان
لا تقل عن اربع الى ست شهور احيانا سنه
ونصف بعض الحالات الشديده همم في كثير من
المستشفيات والعيادات يتم العلاج لمده
اسبوعين او ثلاثه او حتى شهر وهذا لا يؤثر
كثيرا في مرض الادمان ويعاود ال- ال-
المريض التعاطي مره اخرى ويشعر المريض
بالفشل ويشعر الاهلي بالفشل وبالتالي يبقى
هناك همم يعني سمعه سيئه لعلاج الادمان
رغم انه لم يتم بالشكل
الكافي همم كنت حضرتك بتتكلم برده عن
الوصمه لا في بصمه على المدمنين وصمه
شديده في همم يعني كل المجتمعات العربيه
ال- بينظروا للمدمن على انه مجرم وبينذره
المدمن على انه منحرفيا
هو في الواقع مريض وبالتالي لما بتبقى
النظره همم فيها هذه الوصمه بتتجه
المعامله الى الحلول العقابيه يعني كثير
من الدول بتميل الى الحلول العقابيه انه
همم يسجن ال- المدمن او يعاقب باي شكل
وهناك عقاب همم يعني همم
الدكتور محمد ومنى السؤال فيما تبقى لدينا
من وقت الاستفاده من تجربتك باعتقادك ما
الانسب الطريقه الانسب لاخراج هؤلاء من
هذه الدواء للتعامل مع موضوعهم على عده
مستواه لانه مفصل ام لديها ابن مدمن اسره
كامله لديها فرد مدمن او ايا كان او غير
ذلك
مجتمع ونذهب يعني حتى على مستوى الدوله ما
الطريقه او الاستراتيجيه او الخطه التي
يمكن ان نرتكز عليها بدايه هذا الشخص عن
همم
اول حاجه ان احنا نعمل جهود في الوقايه
كثيره جدا لانه علاج الادمان طريقه طويل
وصعب
والنتائج يعني ليست يعني مرضيه حتى الان
في اول حاجه للوقايه ونبذل فيها جهود
كبيره جدا طيب اصيب الابن يعني نحاول ان
احنا نكتشف ده وهو بسرعه وفي اقرب وقت من
اي تغيرات جسديه او نفسيه او اخلاقيه تظهر
عليه وناخذه الى طبيب نفسي متخصص فورا
الطبيب النفسي هيقيم الحال ويشوف هل الشخص
ده يعالج عن طريق العياده الخارجيه ام انه
يحتاج الى الايداع في مصحه ال- ال-
المصحات والمراكز العلاجيه محتاجه لانها
تستوفي المعايير الدوليه لعلاج الادمان
بمراحلها المختلفه من علاج تخليص الجسم من
السموم ثم ثم العلاج السلوكي اللي بيحسن
سلوكيات ال- ال- المريض ثم العلاج
التاهيلي طويل المدى اللي بيعيد بناء
شخصيه المريض انا افضل شخص اشتغلت فيه
وشفته هو المجتمعات العلاجيه انه بيبقى في
مجتمع علاجي يمارس حياته ويبقى فيه رياضه
يبقى فيه جلسات علاجيه يبقى في رحلات
بيخرجها هذه المقترحات فعلا الاذان الصغير
لذلك اشكر ضيفيه الكريمين على هذه
المشاركه القيمه من مدينه المنصوره
المصريه الدكتور محمد مهدي استاذ الطب
النفسي بجامعه الازهر ومن بيروت الى
الاعرج المدير التنفيذي لجمعيه في شبكه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا للحد من مخاطر
استخدام المخدرات طبعا هو موضوع كبير همم
يعني خلاصه ما توصل اليه ضيفنا الكلمات هو
انه لا يجب هؤلاء ب همم بصمه عار تعبير
لكن لعلاجهم يجب ان يتم احتوائهم سواء على
مستوى الاسره المجتمع او حتى على مستوى
اكبر من ناحيه همم الدوله ك بني تحتيه
لعلاجها من اشكركم جزيلا الشكر مشاهدينا
الكرام من عدونا القاكم باذن الله في حلقه
جديده مع بقيه لقصه جديده الاثنين القادم
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]